[Applause]
thousands celebrate as Israeli forces
begin to withdraw after one of the
biggest assaults in more than 20 years
two days of violence leaving a trail of
Destruction and families grieving
nuridin was 16 years old when he was
killed by Israeli fire
his friend was injured we saw him
rushing out to the hospital he was
saying I want to go to the hospital I
want to go to the hospital I told him
not to go I had a feeling that something
would happen
drones bulldozers and more than a
thousand troops swarmed the Janine
refugee camp
the Israeli Prime Minister promising
that this was the first not the last
assault on this densely populated area
at this moment we are completing the
mission and I can say that our extensive
activity in Janine is not a one-time
operation we will continue to uproot
terrorism we will not allow Janine to
return to be a safe haven for terrorism
the operation targeted more than homes
in the camp with tear gas and bullets
fired near hospitals where the wounded
were taken
the aggression against our people in the
city of Janine and its camp and the
deliberate targeting of medical and
emergency personnel and hospitals
culminated this evening with live
shooting at citizens in the Janine
government hospital and the shelling of
the vicinity of the hospital
now returning to the camp hoping the
homes they were forced to flee are still
there and expecting to find more victims
under the rubble knowing that
destruction will take months if not
years to repair
this is a shoe shop it does not contain
explosives nor does it contain Rockets
it's the shoe shop that I live off they
burnt it all down
what Palestinians across the West Bank
say they still have reason to celebrate
they say that the Israeli assault did
not achieve its Target with many
fighters able to escape capture
a recent poll showed that 70 percent of
Palestinians support armed resistance
against Israel's occupation with many
here seeing Janine as an example of
defiance that number is only expected to
rise Ibrahim al-jazeera Ramallah the
occupied West Bank